hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to outlast I don't know
who's banging back there but can you
calm it down until I get into this
episode so we just came down into this
cave and I believe I'm not a hundred
percent sure but I believe oh no oh oh
is that all
Oh Larry you know you shouldn't have
tried to escape I'm just wondering how
you died down here
how did you die down here how did all of
you die down here it looks like you got
crushed and I guess that doesn't bode
well for me even I shouldn't a said dick
diddly-squat
okay all right that's how you're gonna
play well I believe in myself as the
protagonist of this story I think I'm
gonna be okay
unless I'm not the protagonist and I
thought about this I did in between the
last episode in this one I thought about
this what if Blake here and I know
everything's crumbling and falling
around me but I'm just gonna take a
moment about this one
what if Blake here isn't the hero that
we all think he may be because there's a
lot of emotions that was caused people
to remember the past like that or have
that be haunting them and one of the
emotions is guilt and there seems to be
a lot of play on sin okay there seems to
be a lot of people screaming down here
but if they could stop screaming and
then I'd be a much better of what if
Blake isn't so innocent in Jessica's
death
[Music]
it's definitely in front of home be
careful little mouth what you say Oh be
careful they don't mouth hello okay you
just drift off into the distance here
alright oh good let's definitely Oh
a lover's embrace oh good yeah oh that's
nice delightful seems like these people
down here just lived the most fun filled
life you could possibly imagine but
again like I was saying what if what if
Blake somehow was complicit hello
swooshed you gonna get splashed all
right you stay over there and die
horribly I'm gonna press on and squeeze
through here I don't know it's just a
theory at this point a game theory but
if if if it would make sense in terms of
why that first phone call said something
about kissing oh hi hello good to see
you creatures of appetite oh this is my
only face burn this better face
where's lid mother burn mother burned
mother burned mother burned okay I don't
understand
Lord Nick hiding okay congratulations
crazy [ __ ] I show my face okay
good all right you want to see it
oh god no oh boy
oh nice face there that's a good face oh
oh
swoosh oh squash hope for you guys oh
that's what you get
am I about to beat where'd you go
where'd you go where'd you go who died
oh god you didn't go anywhere god damn
it we've to we wind are those totally
mindful that 100% my fault I'm just
gonna start going and you can be back
there and die preferably because
apparently this whole place is going
under and everything is going wrong okay
guys sprint out of the tunnels of the
naked people
then what is everyone's it's all okay
thank you very much for that just gonna
squeeze along here don't rub your true
face on me I'm good with my jovial fake
face if you know what I mean fruit of my
lust are you sure it's my child I don't
know if I want to watch I don't know if
I want to watch at all well that looks
bad I probably shouldn't go under there
I don't know I gotta find it and I gotta
break it yeah I gotta follow these wires
I guess while also avoiding death on
wheels
oh okay you're still there and still
naked good I didn't mean to go this way
there was another way that I was trying
to go and I didn't mean to go this way I
didn't mean to go this way I didn't mean
to go this way I'm going backwards now
god damn it
alright fine you want to play with me
huh you employee go ring around the
rosey baby
all right fine then looks like you just
slows me in this water so I guess it
doesn't matter to you okay so I just got
to follow the wires and find my way back
and then I should be able to get through
there without dying a horrible sappy
death oh here we go I think I'm finding
something
damn it could I stop running out of
breath every few inches geez get some
exercise
okay wait no not that that's not what
I'm into cool that's good oh that's
always a good thing
hey can I climb under there I don't know
where I am but where am I
oh I don't know what I think I made it
to the other side I I think I don't know
where she is I hope you don't mind the
fact that I'm still wearing clothes I
just preferred that way it's awfully
cold down in these drafty mines I turn
that off I turn that off
oh [ __ ] i 100% turned that off oh no
that's where you going
don't see nothing and I turned that off
is there more than one there's got to be
more than one then Oh
each of these split off on a divergent
paths okay so where do you go
oh you criss cross under there okay so
if I can just I can't see [ __ ] but here
we go I think I did that
oh right here okay all right got it
so I just need to find one more I think
it was just three of them and then it's
good oh I didn't even have to crawl
under there that was me being a big dumb
idiot okay so there's one more where
does that go where does it go baby where
does it go where'd it go over there okay
okay come on skedaddle man I thought
that was gonna be your thing so you're
just going there gonna break that or
something but that just goes through
there that doesn't go anywhere was that
the only one weren't there only two then
oh I think that was it okay that was it
here we go
good okay nice trap why didn't they do
that why did they have power down here
anyway Blonsky whoa okay don't ask me
how that worked physically because I
don't know where are we world Oh wowie
Zowie looks like I'm gonna have to do
something about this poo [ __ ] alright
goodbye then
are you going Oh Oh No waiter you come
back okay all right you're coming back
heedless see Rollie pollie and then I
switched watch it
Shubin can't keep a secret from yourself
see that's what I was thinking
sure oh not enough force on that bad boy
all right I get it I need to push it up
and then get a lot more oomph behind it
so that I can smash into this thing Oh
what I can't pull that all I got to pull
it all the way back all right well no
one's behind me
lady if you're there and still make it
just play some strings join the band
back there they'd love your company it's
true face it there's one thing an
orchestra respects it's a true face all
right go for it okay cool hi oh hi why
were you there
why were you there that didn't make any
sense
you still there still there
[Music]
how did you go why were you there in the
first place well that didn't make any
goddamn sense it all
continuing on that's just the water area
again oh I goofed it I goofed it real
good okay well here we go your batteries
soon enough I don't think I have nearly
a Mindlin I've got two nothing matters
but like all nothing matters but wind
okay they went down there there's
nothing over here so I got to go down to
let's see if I can figure oh now I go
down a ladder oh now it works okay
okay what happened you just scream for
nothing man oh okay
lots of dead bodies everywhere goofed
got it I'm currently I don't know if you
love me at all okay you love me very
much apparently rewarm
are you behind me oh you aren't
oh you're crawling by me did you could
you could you could you just oh oh oh oh
god you're very close you're very close
to me and I don't like it oh I don't
like that none oh I don't like this none
at all at all this is not good
paavana boesky pappadimos key oh whoa no
thank you
no no no oh god this claustrophobic
[ __ ] all right I see how it is here
we go here we go here all still crawling
oh that I would have
oh oh oh she might the other way how
about a whiskey oh very very narrow I
can't see anything
all right well that's 200 where are you
okay go that way I guess hey that was
his bliss flat by me
it was that me or was that her oh oh
hi where are you where are you hi hello
hello it's not the glory
oh no no she stowed wife I'm sorry okay
don't know where I'm going that leads to
nowhere you still here in the water
[Applause]
[Music]
apparently I'm not doing okay thought I
saw something no nothing
waste of time
oh boy I think I still hear her in the
darkness mad ain't good if you could
leave me the fridge alone that'd be nice
if anyone could leave me the fudge alone
for just a few seconds that'd be great
why am I here
the [ __ ] was that hello oh hi oh hi
hello what are you doing there with my
knee I mean oh the [ __ ] whiplash
right in my eardrums why were you over
there what am I supposed to do where am
I supposed to go how am I supposed to be
able to get around
Oh
no no no no no
oh okay all right
is that a battery I have that okay go go
go go go go go oh this is a dead end
oh god oh god oh god it's got
Howie Rick and dick is it over there is
our will to go I can't see
oh it's all a red herring it all means
nothing it's nothing oh wait no he was
up here that was so hard to see well
that's the story of this game huh it was
so hard to see yes indeedy-do it was hi
I thought you were I thought you were uh
what's her face Val or whatever it is
oh no is Val gonna be at the top of this
well I'm not healed but hopefully no one
hurts me up there no they would never
hurt me they love me oh yeah I wonder
how many times I bandaged this one wound
how infected could one wound possibly be
the answer is excessively and with many
contaminants such as the leprosy and the
I Rea like such as someone was up there
I don't know if that's important for me
but someone was up there who build this
place and why did they phone it in so
hard
[Music]
nice and easy nice and easy nice and
easy okay nice and easy that way
apparently am I supposed to jump
somewhere is this just a skedaddle II do
n to the road
Oh jump up maybe yeah alright
oh boy okay does this seem familiar
which way am I supposed to go oh not
that way apparently because I don't
think I can go that way
q buddy boos gah hope this doesn't drop
again okay there we go
reloading oh this has been one wild ride
hello
Oh piece of paper ah chapter fifteen and
God spoke from the mouths of Ezekiel so
the disease bled and his teeth cracked
and the seed issued from his inspired
loins and is his words with a blood of
Christ and of this blood was a river and
if sustenance healed the festering wood
of the trees that bore the seven nations
by the blood of the last minor eyed lamb
shall fall forever and they that remain
shall need no light
now the candle no electric flame for
vision shall be an eternal dog seal not
the prophecies of my word but copy them
even exact of letter and with every
waking moment of my life for I am thy
fellow-servant and of thy brethren the
prophet and Father and the Shepherd's
say only this God will reward you be
filthy be just be unjust he closed in
shame or in glory in time God shall [ __ ]
ye with it and so shall be thy reward we
of all of us are Alpha and Omega and
Ezekiel the first among all and he shall
climb the tree of life or be crucified
upon it only the chosen of God shall
find sanctuary within temple gate for
without there are [ __ ] and killers and
idolator's Pharisees publicans
blasphemous
tax collectors and tyrants and the
angels say God turned away from man
until the time his son Jesus Christ came
to testify unto you
Jesus Christ turned away from man until
the time his prophet
Sullivan Nath came to testify unto you
and every one of the Prophet is true for
it is written in this book and this book
is the truth you shall testify these
things and in you shall be the book of
life and you shall live in this holy
city and you shall say come quickly
revelations even in my suffering even in
the death of my children come Lord God
and give me paradise the grace of God
and His Prophet Sullivan auth be with
you oh oh man this Sullivan not sure is
high and mighty of himself and of course
it's the truth because Papa Knauth said
it's the truth and you all wrote it down
word-for-word how truth II it was and
therefore the truth is the truth
circular logic be damned excuse me was
hello hello I see you in there
what are you doing dancing oh I love a
good dance
Oh can I join me nice but oh uh oh hi
what are you doing oh don't do that
now don't thrust your hips like that you
freaking weirdo with your true face
alrighty then Hey
that's mine hey stop it Hey oh you you'd
do your jerks all of you all of these I
did what are you talking about oh that
Lin up there please tell me that's not
Lin I want to watch Oh what am I
watching
Oh
[Music]
oh hi okay hello okay you have to tell
me not unless you answer no fine then
you have to give up if you say I win
I'll let you up okay you have to say it
you win okay
you're such a pushover Blake alrighty
then
[Music]
are you Jessica or are you Lynn I can't
remember if her name was said in this
endeavor hey I want to go oh I thought
we work on this way I thought we're
going through that door over there
alright where are we going and why I
don't know why you have to be so
precious about it well what oh you're
just I don't know
nerd shut up you are
okay she said to ask didn't she maybe I
don't know I just wanted to know you're
a nerd - I know okay thank you
I think so why are we here at what
amounts to be nine o'clock at night
[Music]
are we here why are we here Jessica why
are we here what the hell is happening
every time I've been here before I've
been here revisiting my memories but I'm
literally reliving the exact memories
and parents are home yet
you think I could come over yeah sure
Why Why What like why do you want to
come over I don't know
[Applause]
oh sorry we what are the two of you
doing in here I'm sorry father Lauder
notes we stayed after school for journal
you were just for me let's step back
into class please what what class you're
not in trouble yet Blake you don't want
to get in trouble do you just with me
I want you to tell me what you were
doing in here were you misbehaving no do
I need to call your parents Oh
Jessica do I need to call your father
again no please I only want us to be
friends
nobody's in trouble yet does one of you
think you can make this right Jessica
Jessica look at me will you pray with me
will you help me make this right why
don't you go along home Blake did I
interrupt something between you two it
wasn't like that then what did you want
you won't say you know shame is a gift
from God to let you know right from
wrong and what you want is very wrong
go home and pray hey I wanted Blake
please this is awkward enough nothing's
the matter but I need you to leave us Oh
everything's okay you can leave young
man walk away
where is responsibility what the hell
kind of [ __ ] is this
ah someone down 9-1-1 oh boy maybe
that's where the guilt comes comes from
boy that's probably where the guilts
from I'm on the way oh boy oh boy oh boy
[Music]
you think you saw oh but no no where
where no what the hell
[Applause]
so she never actually hung herself
this is the mast but just all this mess
so oh man I'm just trying to wrap my
head around this and I gotta run away
from that Oh all right here we go again
I guess [ __ ] [ __ ] you alright god
how are you pregnant I don't want to die
here I don't want to baby you die here
oh whoa oh I won't let them kill you
what Oh Oh - get out of here
yeah I'll record this don't worry I know
this is a very impressing moment but I'm
gonna get this for posterity sake I
guess we're gonna follow the fiery moon
or something like that
Oh what is happening here oh well can't
go that way I guess well where are we
going I don't even know anymore haysoms
but it just seems like this place just
brings up all of your darkest memories I
don't know I don't know if it's even
connected Oh
wait can I take a second here wait weird
Lindo alright well hey on land I just
need to see this
we're out I got Jessica there's cold but
the smell we just started we'll find it
going up will tell them what happened I
don't think that's yeah that ain't right
okay well hey Lynn how's it going there
I mean Jessica I guess jeez
Blake has lost his damn mind
he's just so caught up he even said find
an adult like what in the world is that
even about is that the Sun and what does
he mean by skull this clearly isn't
smooth this is the apocalypse we have to
find shelter okay all right yeah
all right and our gun but I think we're
going the right way following the Sun
he's with the four horsemen where's Papa
naath Jesus cuz I just I don't I don't
get it like obviously the past is
haunting him but and obviously three
slaughter milk is a disgusting horrible
human being but my god I can't go that
way
that's all locked off so there's got to
be another way to get around here yeah
whatever your name is let's skedaddle we
got to get going here else we're gonna
die in the storm
jeez oh good yeah this is good
just shove yourself right at home it's
too dangerous
you can't we can't stay out here help me
down please
okay okay
be careful okay I'm coming out yeah I'm
sorry yeah the one thing I wasn't
supposed to do I did that and now you
mean your coccyx is broken too so it's
mine oh this bed looks good Oh
oh geez don't tell me you're gonna run
away from her while we're doing this
oh geez
okay all right there yeah no joke you
you got pregnant in a matter of hours
that's probably bad too bad we gotta
keep going
apparently or else we're gonna die cuz
I'm pretty sure she's devout enough that
she doesn't want this baby to be born so
we're just gonna have to sit down a
little bit longer here how about you go
there no not that bad Paul not comfy
enough for you I see
okay
poisonous
[Music]
oh sweet divine intervention some
declare till that happens alrighty then
off we go Lana didn't look good either
a lot of beautiful do we go back or what
do we do here
no is that bad good enough baby no oh
you're so picky you're so picky when
you're about to birth the Antichrist oh
geez so number one of your cravings
again human blood oh gosh I just went
got your human blood last night
keep on the fiery Sun I guess and this
is this is all an illusion like one's
gotta pee
yeah kinda just like that huh I'm just
willing to put money that this is all in
our minds like this is some orchestrated
thing that's playing out because of some
psychological influence from some that
that device that they were talking about
they're seeing the signs of the
Apocalypse and it doesn't necessarily
mean that it's all true I mean is she
there's no way that is actually the
Antichrist there's no way I can't
believe that like it just
this is the baby cuz it's oh I wonder
you know I just thought I'd ask
you know you never know what it could be
could be a little bit you know no pain
in your lower lumbar bow we can take
shelter that that's a nice card to fight
this you gotta buy to fight
review this foot it whoa did that just
fly up into this guy huh the world is on
fire the baby's coming
yeah the impossible stretches
none of this is my fault yeah okay all
right okay what about this thing no no
too small
hello how are you doing not so good yeah
me neither apparently I'm complaining
a man
Oh up here okay I'm gonna make my way in
the chapel apparently because the best
place to birth the Antichrist is at
church we have to get inside yeah okay
since that other bed wasn't good enough
for you
all right we're in here now papanov are
you gonna pay us a visit
okay oh uh yes the stretching rack great
perfect place lie down you can you can
do this
[Music]
so Lin said you haven't even kissed her
yet
what like in Beauty and the Beast oh you
mean drama the play we're saving for the
like actual night uh-huh
we are okay we like cheek kiss so like I
see your girlfriend tell me or else or
else what I got you again
[Music]
that's the childhood
but they can get out my children
but yours
I'm powerless again
the jobs to stall you've murdered
paradise
God has gone silent since the storm the
birth ooh
will he have if he destroys us all who
will he have left punished
I killed my children all of them every
last one there's no more perfect faith
in that it still
that's hard as you can if you love
anything at all process skull on the I
know God doesn't hear dead men but I
expect he answers them Blake's just like
okay gonna step away from this situation
oh my god I think my whole this whole
episode my face has just been this whole
time go in the confessional can I just
saw him oh my god no I can't even do
that oh yeah let's record this for
posterity you know a few last blips and
laps maybe I should have the camera up
or it'll pop and not but
and I want a beautiful day lovely whoo
so everyone's dead huh imagine that
everyone said everyone in this town died
and no one's left alive even papanov is
dead this is me and this baby
and look at that big bright beautiful
Sun ha ha ha go her Jets burn me up burn
me just burn meal
[Music]
man I still I still can't believe this I
still can what is that Oh No
did they all kill themselves is that
what happened here without a veneer
they'll kill themselves can you have so
get to grow up she'll do everything she
was
we are you talking to talking to
yourself there oh yeah oh yeah
cyanide okay all right yeah well geez
geez so everyone is dead everyone is
dead everyone everyone's dead no and it
was all oh okay what's back here huh
trying to hide some from me Trent had
some for me oh I see you trying to hide
some from me
[Music]
what's going on huh what's going on in
here huh all right fine you're not
trying to hide something
but I'm on me I'm on to you okay where's
over here okay
ah okay it's just all part of the same
memory well thank you that's that's not
very comforting you know to watch and
keep and send me quietly to sleep
watchful savior wash away all I've been
wrong today help me every day to be
gentle gentle
more like thee
oh no it can't be the end
no explain explain no no
so it really was the Antichrist and
everyone's dead the whole world is
ending and everything's gone too literal
hell Bank you know the possibility that
it was all not real but it there had to
have been something about it there had
to have been there was something about
it there was I refuse to believe that
the actual Antichrist came in there and
just no gede everyone into submission
huh there's no way there's no way ah
there's something about that noise and
that light that was a psychological
signal there was some technology and
technology and experimentation happening
I refused refused to believe that was it
there is no way ordinarily I'd give
credence to things like this and be like
maybe you should take it at face value
but no there were pieces of the puzzle
that were there there were pieces of the
puzzle that were there and maybe if you
dug deep enough you would have found the
truth and the truth can only be that
there was some other influence across
the lake there was the power plant those
trees with the fake leaves that that
note said maybe there were more notes
like that and that's the only one that I
found
but it was something even that guy said
in the note that is he got close to them
the visions got more powerful and as I
was moving towards it and and the
heretics in those caves were probably
right on top of the play as far as that
goes and so they had everything
distorted in their mind and for some
reason this psychological thing brings
up old memories and maybe it's a factor
that they're also devout anyway they
were devout anyway so their beliefs were
amplified so hard and their guilt and
their shame and their quote-unquote sin
was amplified to an extreme degree like
they were already a cult look there were
already a cult let's give them that they
were already in this belief system but
when they got there things started
coming to reality because of the
experimentation that must have been
happening to them that has to be it
there is no other explanation but why
didn't you explain anything the Sun
didn't blow up and kill everybody I'm
willing to bet that there's no way you
better tell me something at the end of
these credits you better tell me Sean
I'm just gonna burn there has to have
been something there has to have been
something because I missed many of
things it doesn't show me all the things
I've missed here but it does show a lot
that I've gotten I got a lot of his
things towers of metal this was it five
miles beyond the mines beyond the mines
far side of the mountain so the mines
were the closest thing to them
camouflaged metal towers by a
symmetrical trees I was overcome with
waking dreams as of a power I had never
experienced before there were flames and
in sinks and what have may have been
mouths and may have been sex organs it
really brings out the base level of the
brain the lizard brain the base thing
you know it really tramps on to that and
it amplifies it in some way and it
causes visions and hysteria because
there's I don't know but that's all we
have for now now remember in the
original outlast there was the
whistleblower DLC that shed some more
light on what was happening and in the
end the wall rider seemed like an ethe
the real thing but you know it was it
was explained in the original analyst
and also you know in whistleblower to a
greater detail so I would not be
surprised if this had more now all that
story aside I'm gonna say about outlast
to the game from a gameplay standpoint I
loved that it was different it was
definitely different in certain extremes
about outlast and the experience of that
it was in my opinion it had just a
little too much of the merry-go-round
chasing and running away from people but
it had moments that were just gosh darn
terrifying and I actually really liked
the flipping in and out of reality
aspect of it I think that added a lot of
to it and just showed how whatever was
happening in that world was affecting
Blake and how his past and his main
source of guilt in his entire existence
was brought up and it was amplified to
an extreme degree this was a worthy
successor to outlast but not without his
flaws and I'm sure someone else can
point out its flaws much better than I
ever could but even so it took the
subject matter and it didn't even shy
away an inkling to it it went as deep as
you could possibly go into the
perversion the bloodiness the gooeyness
the horrific nature of this it didn't
skirt around religion it didn't do any
of that it hit it head-on and I can
appreciate something that takes itself
seriously to an extreme degree and
that's what this did and I really really
really enjoyed this I did I loved this
game I did III from a from a gameplay
standpoint there were flaws and there
were story flaws and there's holes
obviously and there's unanswered
questions but from a pure experience
standpoint that was flippin amazing I
had a blast I was frustrated at times
but I never wanted to stop going but
either way I'll leave it at that
let me know what you guys thought of it
down in the comments below I want to
hear your opinions about this I want to
hear your theories about the story I
want to know what is possibly going on
here and how it could in any way relate
to the original outlast because this
wouldn't be outlast to if it might not
be some tangentially related things
we'll see you'll see what happens in the
future and we'll see what gets dug up so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see
in the next video
[Music]